HBO's Watchmen Forge its its own path
but it also doesn't forget where it came
from
it's packed full of covert references
throughout its first season so if you're
curious here are some of the Easter eggs
you might have missed in what might be a
meta joke about Easter eggs Watchmen
features a ton of actual eggs which came
first the chicken or the egg both some
serve as references to the comic series
for example in the first episode as
Angela a bar breaks up egg yolks in a
bowl they formed the smiley face you
might recognize from the cover of the
first issue of Watchmen there are plenty
of other eggs throughout the season that
are more generally symbolic dr.
Manhattan conjures and drinks one during
his first date with Angela in the fourth
episode we see a couple that gets some
much-needed fertility help from the
mysterious lady true spilling eggs on
their porch and during the series finale
Angela finds one egg left unbroken among
the others she smashed to the ground
earlier in the evening dr. Manhattan
left that egg behind after his death as
a way of transferring his powers angela
consumes the egg but whether she has his
powers is left ambiguous let's jump back
to the smiley face image naturally show
creator Damon Lindelof and his crew
found other ways to work the iconic
visual into the show particularly the
blood spatter on the comedian's yellow
button the first episode of Watchmen
opens on a horrific depiction of the
Tulsa Race Riot of 1921 which remains
one of the most devastating instances of
racial violence in US history white
citizens attacked Greenwood a primarily
african-american neighborhood looting
robbing and killing with abandon in
watchman's universe descendants of the
attack were paid reparations causing
resentment among white supremacists in
that sequence the show sneaks in a
terrible tragic reminder of the button a
blood spatter on the head of young will
Reeves that perfectly mimics the smiley
face a similar blood splatter can be
spotted later in the same episode on
Judds badge during his hanging watchmen
takes place in a world quite different
from ours
where Nixon never resigned and Robert
Redford was the president that followed
him a lot is different culturally -
including the popular reading material
Mac Shea's pirate yarn tales of the
black freighter is prominent
featured and excerpted in the original
comic that explains why there are so
many references to pirates in the show
specifically a detective named pirate
Jenny a costumed aunt by one of Angela's
children a skull and crossbones wax seal
on the game wardens letter a pirate flag
the name of Laurie's hotel and more
several characters are also spotted
reading a book called fog dancing in
quick blink and you'll miss it shots
another novel written by the prolific
fictional Shae seems like it's pretty
good too would you let me give you
another book when a young Angela looks
at a series of VHS tapes in the show's
seventh episode one of them is a
Hollywood adaptation of Fogg dancing
both versions of niteowl were major
characters in The Watchmen comic but his
story doesn't get much play in the show
the show is however rife with actual
owls and references to the nocturnal
Birds Laurie even has a pet owl what's
his name oh the owl who that's his name
Angela's other daughter dresses as an
owl and the kids also have a few owl
toys visible on their dresser plus when
Angela Dawn's night vision goggles
she looks eerily like night owl himself
the first night owls famous tell-all
book under the hood also makes a cameo
in the first episode a copy of the book
is on doomed sheriff Judd Nelson's desk
when Angela stops by his office and
during their subsequent chat she sips
coffee from an owl shaped mug one of the
big questions in the early episodes of
the season was where dr. Manhattan was
hiding was he on Mars as widely believed
or somewhere else as it turned out he
was hiding in plain sight as Calais bar
supportive loving husband to Angela
after the two fell in love dr. Manhattan
took on the appearance of a regular
human and had Angela wiped his memory so
he could live as normal a life as
possible at least for a while there are
plenty of clues leading up to Cal's big
reveal other characters are skeptical
about Cal's accident that left him with
amnesia it's a car crash right I've done
a lot of research on memory total
amnesia is extremely rare and he and
Laurie a former lover of dr. Manhattan
seemed to have a special connection
right off the bat in the 8th episode we
learn how he and Angela met two very
specific
musical cues accompany dr. Manhattan
throughout the episode mr. blue by the
Fleetwood's and a riff on George
Gershwin's Rhapsody in Blue
in the Watchmen universe the u.s. wins
the Vietnam War decisively thanks to dr.
Manhattan's help and President Richard
Nixon is exalted as a hero Vietnam
becomes the 51st state and Nixon is
remembered as an American icon
throughout the series Viet Nam's
inclusion in the United States is
addressed rather broadly angela grows up
there and saigon is mentioned repeatedly
as an american city during Judd
Crawford's funeral the flag draped over
his coffin looks very different from the
real flag and it buries 51 stars during
the show's pilot when Looking Glass
interrogate SAS suspect inside a
mysterious chamber that shows
alternating patriotic and disturbing
images Nixon's face can be seen on a
revised Mount Rushmore the bar in Saigon
where Angela and dr. Manhattan first
meet is called mr. Edie's bar a direct
reference to the comics and the site of
one of its most horrific events Eddie
Blake also known as the comedian took up
with a Vietnamese woman during the war
but when she became pregnant he lost
interest in her after the unnamed woman
slashed Blake's face with a beer bottle
leaving a scar he shot her in the face
at mr. Eddie's and killed her the
director of the episode
Nicole Cassell told polygon that the
show's production crew used two
descriptions from the comic to inform
what the interior of mr. Eddie's would
look like
dr. Manhattan explains towards the end
of the season that everything that will
happen has either already occurred or is
happening right now making every outcome
inevitable
he's also notably the son of a
watchmaker as such there's a clock motif
that runs through Watchmen connecting
dr. Manhattan's thought process and
wisdom to Adrian Veidt Veidt who spends
years imprisoned on Europa with cloned
servants created by dr. Manhattan as his
only company writes a play for the
clones to perform called the watchmaker
son it's a retelling of dr. Manhattan's
origin story though it burns one of the
clones to death rather than giving him
superpowers beyond that there are plenty
of clocks in the show all of which
reference the comics Doomsday Clock as
well as its final cover which itself
depicts a bloody clock check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a
single one
[Music]